he's a force on the field for the los
angeles chargers and a game changer when
it comes to serving others
and making the world a better place and
he's doing it all
one t-shirt at a time isaac rochelle
thank you for chatting with me
oh no doubt i'm super excited to be uh
to be talking to you
tell me about local human it started
really off of i want to give back as
soon as the quarantine started i got a
dog like most people
um and because of that i got to know
other dog owners
and one guy in particular trevor beck
we just kept having conversations about
the pandemic and how it was affecting
different people
and we decided to take action so we
created local human
we just knew if we you know tried to
sell t-shirts
and gave people an easy opportunity to
try to donate
through their t-shirt purchase we could
make a massive difference
in our first campaign we were able to
donate five thousand dollars to meals on
wheels
now it's been 10 months we've donated
over a hundred thousand dollars
we partnered with no kid hungry the
national fair housing alliance a college
fund for african american students
um we we donated to the american
foundation for suicide prevention
and we're continuing to identify um you
know different organizations that need
help
and we're trying to find a way to
support them sometimes it can be
overwhelming for people to think about
where to donate or how to donate or can
i trust them
we like to take all of that out of the
equation and all you have to worry about
is buying a shirt for every shirt
purchase we also donate a shirt
so we donated thousands of t-shirts to
foster centers we kind of want to prove
like we go a step further like
you can do more than donate just one for
one
we're gonna donate you know all our
proceeds i love that
you're so right i think there are so
many people at home
who want to give back and want to
donate their time and resources but feel
stuck
especially in this pandemic what would
your advice be to those people
i think if you want to give back don't
overthink it when i sat down with trevor
and when we were talking about these
issues we realize like this is not like
something that we need to overthink like
we can go attack this
you know it's very obvious that the work
you're doing has
a huge impact on the people that you're
helping but how has this work
changed you it's this idea of altruism
and paying it forward and that for me is
really really fulfilling i mean this is
like
a dream come true for me we had an event
we had a thanksgiving drive-through
where we fed
450 families in santa ana and we had a
lady who was
volunteering she came to me after and
she was crying and she was just
explaining you know how fulfilling that
day was for her
i think sometimes when we think about
volunteering and when we think about
giving back
we only think about the underprivileged
under-resourced
i think we we need to also think about
you know the people
like this lady it's this idea good for
you better for others right like
it feels good to donate local human
it's such a young organization it's
still in its infancy
yet you guys have done so much with it
where do you hope to go from here
the good thing about this is we don't
care about making money i'm in the nfl
i don't need a salary from this so my
only focus
is taking every dollar to impact people
so you know we're in a good position to
just
go crazy have fun and impact a lot of
people's lives
you're nominated for the walter payton
man of the year award for your
charitable work
off the field for being a positive
influence in your community
how does it feel to be recognized by the
nfl and by your team
for the work you're doing it's huge for
me and there's a mission to recognize
how blessed i am in my position and to
maximize that
as much as i can but it's just it's such
an honor you know
to to have my teammates and peers
recognize that it really is an honor who
are you rooting for on sunday
you know what to be honest with you i
don't care who wins i want to be in the
super bowl
so who cares but i'll be one tell you
that i'll be definitely watching